The holiday season less Merry
and bright as covid-19 continues
to hammer the US as new strains
emerge overseas joining us now
Admiral Brett jawa member
of the White House coronavirus
task force Admiral welcome
to Fox News Sunday great to be
here.
Thank you for having me on TSA
checkpoint travel numbers reveal
more than $1 million per day
traveling leading up
to Christmas despite those covid
warnings do you expect a spike
in New cases as a result sir
well it really depends on what
the Travelers do when they get
where they're going we know
the actual physical act
of traveling in airplanes
for example,
can be quite safe
because of the air purification
systems what we really worry
about is the mingling
of different bubbles once you
get to your destination over
Thanksgiving we saw a mixed
picture in the Midwest
and in the northern plains cases
continue to go down despite
the travel which meant that
people really did the kinds
of things we talked to them
about like wearing a mask
and limiting you're gathering
so we really have to wait
and see.
I really encourage people
to follow the CDC guidelines
make your family gatherings
small safe protect the elderly.
And we can get through this.
There are concerns about a new
variant or mutations
of the virus in places like
the United Kingdom Japan even
Canada Ontario's chief medical
officer announced Saturday that
they had confirmed two cases
they're considering global
travel.
Do you think this new strain is
now here in the United States.
Well we don't know if it's here
or not we would say that
there's certainly a possibility
that it's here already
because of global travel
and it's in so many countries
now let me tell you what we know
about the strain it is number
one it is not any more serious
than the normal strains of covid
however it does appear to be
more transmissible there's not
direct evidence of that.
But there's lots of suggestive
evidence but again you can still
protect yourself
by the mitigation measures
and we have no evidence
to suggest nor do we believe
that this vaccine that
the vaccine would not be
effective.
In other words, we do believe
the vaccine will be effective
against this variant
so that's why we're so excited
and still very enthusiastic
about the vaccine program which
is being rolled out on time,
on schedule with almost 15
and a half million doses being
distributed by this week
upcoming the United States is
requiring negative tests from
travelers coming from the United
Kingdom do we need that
elsewhere is that enough at this
point.
So I think what's often not
talked about is since March
there's been a very substantial
travel restriction on UK
and a variety of countries from
from Europe.
So since March, we have had
a decrease of 92 95%
of travelers coming from the UK
which is our first line
of defense, which other
countries did not have the added
testing puts an extra layer
and that's very important.
There's no perfect silver bullet
but a test three days before now
the CDC can't order testing once
you're in state 2 after that
but we would certainly encourage
states to have quarantine orders
or to have testing once these
travelers arrive so 95% decrease
already the extra testing puts
another barrier in the states
could also impose things.
So I think we're going to be
pretty safe with these as again
we roll out vaccines which are
going to be highly effective
against all the strains that are
out there to those covid
vaccines we've seen first
responders some high profile
politicians rolling up
their sleeves who's next in line
to receive the shots well
in the first wave it has really
been our health care workers
and those in nursing homes
the next wave is going to be
different by state the general
recommendations are those over
75 and certain frontline workers
but it's going to vary state
by state let me talk about
Governor Abbott in Texas he
really is going to prioritize
anyone over 65
because those are the people who
go to the hospitals.
It's not the front line 24 you
a worker who is at low risk
of getting the infection
and at very very low risk
of getting serious results from
that.
But over 65 yes
that's who's in the hospital
and certain other people like
cancer patients or people with
sickle cell disease governor
DeSantis in Florida is
prioritizing everyone over 70
so I think you're going to see
variability and I think that
variability is critically
important
because as the hospitals fill up
the first priority really needs
to be to save lives
and to reduce the burden
on hospitals you're seeing that
in Texas and Florida and you
will probably see that in many
other states interesting OK
so how important is it
for President Trump to receive
the vaccine in terms of building
that critical public confidence
well I of course think that
the president should get a
vaccine at the right time 75
million people voted for him he
has a devout followers and I
think it would set an example I
would say the there is a medical
reason and I don't know I'm not
his physician so I don't know
exactly right but he did receive
monoclonal antibodies within
the last couple of months
and there is sort of guidance
about waiting 60 to 90 days
after a monoclonal antibody
because it could interfere with
the actual vaccine
but of course, President Trump
for his own protection
and to set an example for the 75
million people who voted
for him.
I think it's a great idea
currently the emergency
authorization is for people
at least 16 and older what about
younger children isn't that
important in terms of getting
them back to school well we all
as a pediatrician we certainly
want to have the data to show
that it's safe and effective
in children we don't have that
yet that is coming though 16
and above for one vaccine 18
and above for the moderna
vaccine but I think it's very
important for listeners
to understand that getting
children back to school right
now is safe now there's data
upon data upon data that
children could go back to school
safely in person there was
a recent study in
the memoir that said of all
the places children are likely
to turn positive school is not
one of them.
So it is safe and very important
to get children back in school
even before they are vaccinated.
Now with the community rates
going down we hope after
the holidays
because we're seeing that trend
right now.
And with vaccines it will be
even safer because they'll be
less spread in the community
but children do not need
a vaccine to go back to school
safely it's vital
for their health to get them
back physically present as soon
as possible.
What about their teachers should
they be higher on the priority
list in terms of vaccinations
with millions of American
parents worried their children
are not learning in online
school well they're probably
going to be higher on the list
than the general public but they
certainly don't fall
into the category of the current
asep recommendations
or what's happening in Texas
or Florida in many other states
young healthy teachers should be
at no more risk than young
healthy individuals in any other
profession so I would imagine
that those and they are critical
infrastructure.
We love our teachers that
they're going to be higher than
the general public
but they're certainly not going
to be in the next level
on almost any state
because they're not at higher
risk unless they are at higher
risk if they have hypertension
or sickle cell disease
or a cancer survivor over 65
of course they go in that
category but otherwise
they're probably going to be
further down the priority scale
because we need to take care
of those who are vulnerable who
will be hospitalized first.
And I think you're you're seeing
that both by the recommendations
as well as by several states it
feels like we're waiting
for the point when the United
States gets to Herd immunity
what's your current estimate
so Herd immunity when we get
to Herd immunity that is when
the pandemic is essentially over
now there could be pockets
in certain places where
their vaccine hesitancy
and people don't get vaccinated
the truth is nobody knows
exactly the number but based
on mathematical models as we
have it right now it is
somewhere between 70% and 80%
of individuals having gotten
the vaccine or having gotten
the natural infection now
obviously we want to develop
Herd immunity by people getting
the vaccine
because they're at no risk
of ill health effects
or spreading it to other
individuals somewhere in that
70% to 80% range is probably
the sweet spot nobody knows
for sure but based
on mathematical models people
kind of converge at that number
Admiral we're running out
of time but final question when
do you expect that any American
who wants a vaccine should be
able to get the vaccine well we
are clearly on schedule 20
million vaccinations distributed
by the First week in January we
expect another 30 million
in January another $50 million
in February and with the current
contracts even with just
the vaccines we have right now
we still expect that any
American
who wants a vaccine can be
vaccinated by June that's really
very exciting that means
a couple million people being
able to be vaccinated by that
time.
So with good mitigation steps
with increasing vaccinations
particularly among those who are
vulnerable.
We should see clearly light
at the end of the tunnel.
But we've got to keep discipline
got to keep vigilant right now
as we vaccinate Admiral thank
you for joining us.
Thanks for your service.
We wish you a happy and very
healthy new year.